[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
mm-hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hi my name is brian wood i'm the
technical communications and outreach
manager at wolfram
i'm here today with one of our senior
software engineers
todd reichert and todd is going to give
us a look at his process
for exploring etl with the wolfram
language
uh how you doing today todd good how are
you good
excellent uh let's uh let's start with a
little bit of background
what exactly is etl and kind of what
what got you into this project
uh well the the actual
project was hey we need to get some
analytics out of a log file
um and from that i just kind of dug in
and kind of put myself in the box of
using wolfram technologies
as much as i could during this process
and then the thing that i realized after
i completed it
was that i had done something very
synonymous with what the enterprise
world calls etl
gotcha so so what exactly uh
when people refer to etl what exactly is
it that they mean
oh you want to go ahead and start
sharing that that's part of
part of my presentation go ahead jump in
let's jump right in okay
so
so as you alluded to you know as i
alluded to you know
this this background is you know what
what
kind of kicked it all off for us kick it
all off for me
um and you asked about what etl is
simply put it's extract data transpose
it manipulate it to whatever needs
you need and then load it into a
database
and then i i can't help but notice you
have database sort of in quotes there is
is that sort of to imply that it's
whatever data structure or
exactly yeah yeah and and so
you know the next thing that i have here
is
um the the wikipedia page um and i
i went and read the wikipedia page to
make sure that i i wasn't making things
up you know but
what what i did was very much in line
with what what that is
and etl is a tool that's been you know
um
used for data warehousing for years and
data warehouse reporting and things like
that
and so um that's etl
so all right so what uh
can you kind of guide us through what it
is that you actually did
just step by step to do this etl
so so so the first thing you do is you
figure out how to extract data
so my particular data was coming from
log files um
so if you look at the example log file
there it has the date and the sequential
number on it
um it had one to thirty thousand records
in it um each day contains
i get about a hundred files for each day
um and and what it turned out was the
data contained a lot of noise
a lot of noise that i had to you know
this is
you know this is where i had to go into
design because um if i was to just load
up
all of these log files into a database
the database would just get huge
but when it turned out was i had to look
forward and go what what analytics are
they wanting and that's where i figured
out what the noise was and then i
figured out how to
um in the next step to transpose you
know i'll talk about how i
avoid the noise but you know for this
extract
you know it sounds pretty darn simple
you think you'd open up a file
and you process it well
some of the things that wolfram language
did that you know just
kind of opened the doors for me on this
one was something as simple as
the the dates in other words when when
my scheduled job runs at night
i need to know what today's date is and
yesterday's date is
so you know i was able to use wolfram
languages
yesterday i mean that makes it one it's
easy to
to see and read yeah you know so every
part about that
yeah and so it was like so i i was able
to figure out you know what log files do
i need to
do i need to process today you know so
the dates okay great
well now i take that pattern you know so
now i have a pattern
a file name pattern that i know i need i
can use wolfram language's command
file names to go out to a directory say
here's the pattern with the dates
and give me this list of files great
okay next thing that came along that was
like uh oh
they're zip files well you can't read a
zip file
um wolfram language actually has a
command called um
extract archive and you know it it takes
a file
unzips it puts it in a temporary
directory for you
great now i'm ready to go now my extract
you know is
is kind of ready to go raring to go and
as a quick side note the wolfram
language also has a nice delete file so
once again i had this list of files
sitting in a temporary directory that
when everything's all said and done i'm
done processing
i just loop over with delete file over
this list of
the files that got you know unzipped so
so the extract went really smoothly
you know more so than you know that's
typically not something you would maybe
you know a lot of programmers would step
outside of a language they would use
more systemy type things to do that but
wolfram language was able to do that
yeah it's almost uh i i appreciate the a
lot of the file
based uh functions that we that are in
the wool from language nowadays and i
find that uh it
you almost want to skip over the command
line step you know
you're sort of like well you know i i
can do this right in my notebook so why
not
yeah um uh i know you were mentioning
patterns for um
like you like each each file name sort
of falls into a particular pattern so is
that
you're talking about string patterns
that you used for sort of
matching those file names yeah yeah so
basically i passed into the file names
command
you know here here's that standard
static prefix and then here's this
dynamic
date and you know getting that list of
files
you know like say it was typically
something that i you know i i would have
done
outside of wolfram language before i
would have thought about going from
language
and like say so that that was a nice you
know
as i dug into this and put myself into
that nope i'm going to use wool for my
language you know it just kept
you know i was able to stay in there the
whole time every time i'd hit that
challenge point i was able to dig around
and yep i can find a function that can
help me so
yeah yeah so you ready for transpose
yeah yeah that's
right let's talk about transpose okay so
now transpose unfortunately this is this
is a smallish looking slide but this is
where all of the
all of the the good stuff happens um
you know this is where as i mentioned
before very noisy data
um you know it had a lot of um
entries into it that was just to these
like static files that we really don't
care about
you know we don't care about tracking
those you know so um i was able to
once again you know use wolfram language
and all of its capabilities to just
take that take that noise put it to the
side
and there's actually a second type of
noise that i had a minorly keep
too so you know once again that will
from language handle that like a champ
too you know so
you know i had three degrees i had noise
ignore i had noise that i wanted to kind
of keep a little bit of track of and
then i had the stuff that i really
wanted to keep track of so
you know wolfram language did that um
nice and smoothly but then in the
meantime too you know as as this
slide points out too um you know within
this data
there was two things for sure i p
address i features doesn't tell you much
but you know there's tools out there
that you can take an ip address and
find out like country information right
from and so you know
wolfram language naturally has that
ability to to get that information
and then the user agent field um if i
can say
there would be another talk about user
agent field that
um i dig deeper into how we solved that
one
or how i solved that one so um
the the places you know during this
transpose that you know will from
language like say that the pattern
matching and the string functions
you know whenever you're getting data
and you're prepping it for a database
you you have to have strong string
functions you have to have the ability
to twist and turn the data however you
need
um there was another great aspect you
know
as i'm loading this you know we're
talking about on a daily basis a
100 000 records maybe you know
you know you don't want to you don't
want to keep doing lookups
every time so so with within
the the processing as soon as i run
across something
that i have to do a lookup or a little
extra work for i do the work and then i
cache it
and so well from language made it really
easy for me to keep caches during this
processing thus
speeding it up too you know initially
when
you know when i talked about earlier you
know just kind of throwing everything in
you know it it turned out to be like a
24-hour process
it's like that's not going to work you
know so so you know i
you know through through some design
engineering you know you get it down to
you know 20 minutes you know once again
um you know a lot of this stuff that i
do too is uh
kind of a work in progress but you know
you know you you kind of reach a point
of diminishing returns on
on your code to where it's like okay
it's running good enough we can get it
into production
you know whenever it's running at 1am it
doesn't matter whether it's running two
minutes or 20 minutes
right right at the moment you know in
the future you know and
that's that's what's nice you know once
again wolfram language you know i was
able to consistently
you know as i found these um
unacceptable time frames you know i was
able to continue to
dig dig down and dig deeper and continue
to get that
and then the last bullet point here was
kind of what i alluded to with the ip
address you know wolfram language
you know in the middle of this transpose
you know i have this
piece of data but i need some
information about it oh i need to go out
to the internet
you know or i need to make a web call
you know to some place
get some information boom it's back so
you know that that was all naturally
built into it so
so i i feel i feel compelled to ask just
because you mentioned ip address
um because there are sort of two
different classes of
uh the string versus the text functions
in the wolfram language
uh did you get any use out of things
like uh
text contents or or anything like that
where
because there that will search for the
ip address
as an object rather than writing out a
string pattern do you know what i'm
talking about
um the mark here with this comment
no no i am the the
i mean as far as the ip address um
you know it had to be fairly a quick
look up so that that was part of
gotcha okay you know i i really i
couldn't
i can't utilize slow services so you
know that was part of it you know so
yeah yeah i was just curious because
it's you know it's the difference
between saying
find me an ip address and okay find me
something that matches you know
these digits with a dot then another set
of digits with the dot then
you know actually writing out manually
the ip address
you know um yeah i mean it i
i was able to just use it as a string um
i didn't actually yeah
um the the log files actually come in a
very structured format so i was able to
just go out there and
okay yeah yeah it was kind of like
position four is the ip address boom
gotcha yeah so i really did i didn't
have to go searching for it or anything
so yeah okay that makes sense cool so
then uh
what what's the uh the final step here
so the final step is load that one's
even less interesting
because really it's just a matter of now
transpose does all of that work to get
your data primed really
all's that you're doing is just shoving
it into um in my case
you know sql commands to get into the
database um
you know but once again i didn't have to
leave
i didn't have to leave my preferred
language you know i was able to use the
the database link technologies that will
from language has built into it
to get that data loaded up in a very
easy fashion
um and and as you were alluding to too
um
string and date functions came in a heck
of a lot of uh
use here because um your chosen data
base or wherever you store your data
most likely they're going to store
dates in a in their own type of fashion
so
having the that ability with wolf from
language which has
you know a large set of date um
capabilities you know i was able to dig
in
fine you know basically have my date
which looks
oh it's acceptable but you know twist it
and turn it into
the proper format for the database i was
using so yeah yeah and that's i
i do find that uh the language
recognizes almost any date format where
you sort of
it'll it'll figure it out for you yes
and so
um so so that that was load
so that that's etl um that's
you know that that's what the you know
people
pay lots of money for etl tools um
you know i was able to do this all
within the wolfram language
um you know this next slide here i want
to talk about is the reporting so
i just kind of wanted to bookend that's
kind of the end of etl
um the aspect i want to bring up next is
reporting which
does kind of naturally grow into the
next step
you know a lot of times etls are
connected with data warehouses which
then in turn do reporting so um
the the initial uh need for reporting
for me was i i i set this thing
up on my laptop and used notebooks
to do the whole thing so i was used to
seeing my daily processing in a very
pretty way at the end you know it you
know
it was it was easy to read and easy to
see when something went a flutter
um and so i i was like well
well from language has templating had
has reporting so i i
started researching you know how do i
use a template because
you know i'm not doing anything too
fancy here you know it's just a matter
of reporting hey this log
file had the these results out of it
and so i i researched reporting and
templates and
it just it just worked um you know um
i i believe i talked about this in the
in the next few and
another slide but where i talk about you
know how i moved
this to a server and you know and you
know the
the convenience of the notebook um
doing something like reporting you know
wasn't going to work on the server
so i had to you know refactor it for
that um
but but anyway yeah like say so so
reporting and templating just
worked out great um i was able to
replicate what i did on the notebook on
the server
um real easy and then really to bring
this thing full circle
um we we you know i have these web logs
i've investigated them you know created
a data design
everything now it's the whole point of
this whole thing they want a weekly
report that kind of tells
hey what what's what's going on in these
log files so
once again i i developed the weekly
report on my desktop
doing everything by hand you know
decided
you know realized hey hey i can use this
reporting in this templating
moved it over to the server pull you
know pull all the data
out put it into the template and now now
you know this this date this daily
processing happens at 1am when i'm
well asleep and and on tuesdays
it it does a weekly report and it all
gets sent to me you know
in an email and i pretty much stayed all
within the wolfram language box um so
yeah so that that
and so that i was reporting so
uh so do you have any questions there
before i jump into
my other oh i was just curious if you
could give a
kind of a an overview of the kinds of
things that you'd put in one of those
reports just to give
give people an idea of the depth of the
thing
so i i think i think it's okay to share
basically we're we're wanting to know
who's down you know what what what's
getting what products are getting
downloaded
you know i don't think that's
proprietary to share
um of you know i i don't think it's you
know wrong for us to
want to know who's who's down you know
you know what what products are getting
downloaded so really that that's what
i'm doing
i'm downloading um i'm monitoring the
logs
for people downloading products but then
within the product
you want to know what you know the
product the version and the platform
and so um you know simple reporting
really wouldn't give that to you because
i kind of gotta extract
that um platform and version
from the path sometimes that the people
take to get to the file
so a lot of that um i i'm able to track
bandwidth you know for a given day um
you know like how
you know what how how fast were we
running um
with this user agent analysis we're kind
of being we're gonna we're able to see
what browsers people are using
um things like that um so yeah so it's
things like that and then
basically um you know as i move forward
what i'm hoping is to move beyond the
report and into something
a little bit more dynamic for my users
um which once again the
the etl gets the data in there i'll
maybe have a few static reports but you
know the next step for me will be to
create some sort of dynamic ui
right on so so people can ask you know
about
a you know product in a specific version
and say hey how's
the downloads of this thing going yeah
that would be uh
i mean i think anybody would agree that
that's a pretty convenient interface for
sort of uh keeping track of those kinds
of things yeah
so um so it the the really the
the kind of the the neat thing i did
want to kind of really
drive home uh with what i also did here
was
um i did all of this on my local laptop
and you know i got my proof of concept
working i got my report kind of okayed
um you know and then i just started
moving it over to a server
um you know i work on a mac laptop and
so i got my
i got my os and i got my terminal
you know behind it behind me and i moved
it over to a unix or linux-based server
where we're you know where i'm doing
this again and it just
i mean i'm not going to say it wasn't it
wasn't it didn't just flow over
straight straight but really it was
really just more formatting
you know it didn't i didn't have to like
change
any of my code i didn't have to change
any of my design i really just had to
like reformat it
you know from running things
interactively on the notebook to running
things in packages and functions
you know on on on linux and so
you know i i'm i was you know
this was something i really hadn't had a
chance to do yet in my career here at
wolfram
and i i've just been extremely impressed
with you know the ability
to run run wolf from a language on the u
on the linux command line
unix command line it it's been on par
with every other unix power tool out
there
um that i've ever used um and like say
i'm staying all
pretty much within the wolfram language
box you know at the ends there may be a
little bit of
standard unix stuff but basically that
whole that whole
meat of that process is is within that
wolfram language and so i've been very
very um impressed um
and hopeful that you know i'm going to
continue down you you know continue down
that path
so yeah and that's almost even more
convenient in some ways that
you know the fact that you know you can
you can stick that
those wolf from language expressions and
you know pieces of code sort of in the
middle of your
uh linux command line kind of uh
workflow and it it just you know does
what it does and
you don't have to you don't have to mess
with you know changing your code around
or anything like that yeah
yeah definitely so yeah anybody who's uh
interested in linux mathematica on the
links command line
i highly highly it's it's worth the
investment
of time if if you're unix junkie uh yeah
and
and if anyone watching this hasn't heard
of it uh wolf from script
is is a nice way to yeah sort of start
playing around with that you can you can
pretty much run any wolfram command from
uh
yeah just about any command line
actually
um all right well we are we're just
about out of time here okay
yeah go ahead so yeah yeah final
thoughts is you know
as i mentioned before you know it's
still a work in progress um
but but it solved the problem i had you
know i
i you know i would run across a little
hitch which
any any technology any language i've
ever learned in the past
you know you you you get over it you
know the problem you know
some languages you don't get over it you
know i was able to get over
everything you know in from start to end
i never had to hop out and do anything
else
you know use another technology uh you
know
as i was saying before well from
language on linux
um hopefully um you know
a video like this or more common you
know more uh
maybe ways to get people interested in
wolfram on on linux command line you
know could be a good on-ramp for a lot
of enterprise customers
um especially those that maybe already
have access to a wolfram site license
because people like front ends and
things like that and like the analytics
side you know maybe we could
start getting some people in in the back
back ends of company
you know uh you know down at that server
level interested in using it
um and you know kind of the the caveat
of this whole thing i didn't get show a
lot of code because
you know that this process right now one
is pretty fresh
um to you know for me to be able to
strip out
all of our all of our stuff you know
would have been a little bit much but
you know what what what what could
happen in the future is if there's
enough
interest um you know with there there
there could be something we could create
that maybe it'll be just like a sample
etl type concept to people
um you know that's you know it shows
them just you know
some complexity of extract some
complexity of transposed load and then
maybe a little bit of reporting so
you know if you know something that's
very simplistic that a lot of people
could start from you know because
as you know with anything in life a lot
of times just that sample
that sample project is all you need to
to get
and so um with with this particular you
know project
the fact that it took me didn't take me
that long to
to get it up and running you know you
know having a sample small project for
people to basically
start their um you know their effort in
with
boom you know i i think it would help so
great yeah
so yeah uh it seems like
you you managed to do something pretty
impressive with not too much time and uh
you know something that is fairly in
demand in the industry like you said so
hopefully there's some some folks out
there who are
watching this who might take the
initiative and try it themselves
uh if not maybe maybe we'll have
something in the near future that
uh they can sort of go off of so yeah
thanks
thanks for talking to us today no
problem thank you
thanks for joining us you can check out
other wolfram tech talks live coding
streams and more
on the wolfram research youtube channel
or see what else is new at wolfram.com
you